[Music]
here's another thing like like wing chun
and things like that like yeah that'll
work
if you guys know what the [ __ ] he's
doing and you chain punch I'm dead
that's not good hit somebody 17 times in
the head yeah they're not expecting
never trained before definitely not good
very effective are you gonna get that
off on someone who actually knows what
they're doing I don't know man I'm gonna
get that off on a high school wrestler
good luck good double leg was like
you're going flying it's your head on
the curb yeah it just it just seems to
me that like did you see that video that
is becoming a huge issue in China that a
Chinese Tai Chi master tried to fight an
MMA fighter and just got obliterated in
ten seconds oh and this guy's had to
hide this Chinese MMA fighters had to go
into hiding because people are offended
that he battered this Tai Chi master and
made their country look bad yeah because
it's making their their traditional
martial art look ineffective yeah that's
not that doesn't make sense to me here
we can watch this real quick but I don't
know why the [ __ ] this guy didn't
understand what was gonna happen when
they thought they sometimes I think they
actually believe what they're saying
this is so brutal though this Tai Chi
guy what's really bizarre is Tai Chi's
not really a physical fighting martial
art it's supposed to be something that's
more of like a meditative it's like a
yoga it's like a yoga deal it's supposed
to be grateful I had one of my one of my
buddies black belt guy named Jeff Higgs
old-school jujitsu guy and he got told
by a Tai Chi guy you know you can't take
me down Oh God and my buddy
see that yeah I mean that guy just got
obliterated yeah and the only way you
can ever actually know what would happen
if someone punches you in the face is to
train that wing if you just have these
ideas in your head that you're gonna
stand in front of them this guy's just
oozing blood all over the place and
getting up he's battered it's noses
shattered wobbly I guess my first time
he's ever been punched maybe the MMA guy
should have if he had a little bit more
foresight on what's gonna happen he
should have come out and like really
done the whole you know respect and then
the bow and then all this stuff and then
after defeating him should have helped
him if he maybe that would have
helped him from from a political
standpoint hmm
but yeah because wonder yeah but you
know it seems to me that this is
something that they need to see they
really do because there's too many
people out there that are just buying
into this foolish [ __ ] well like I said
so my buddy Jeff Higgs got this this I
think was an Aikido guy does Aikido
people say Chi and all that I don't know
I cavity they probably do well depends
on which [ __ ] whether whether it was
Aikido or whether it was Tai Chi I
forget but the guy says you know hey I'm
a martial artist and once I settle my
Chi you can't even take me down so how
are you gonna do Jiu Jitsu on me and he
says what what do you mean you can
settle your chases you know I once I
Center my Chi and it's based into the
ground you won't be able to move me you
can try it if you want and my friend
Higgs goes uh okay cool tell me when
you're cheese all centered and the guy
you know does his little thing and then
settle it's his Chi and he says okay I'm
ready and Jeff just did I mean it's no
big deal just hit a double leg on boom
you know like you can't stop a double
leg without defending it without falling
and yeah so they say the guy actually
believed that the guy actually believed
that that's a type of mental illness it
is but I mean you know it's flat earth
right it's I've got a couple people that
are you know now every time I talk about
jujitsu at all they're like Flat Earth
Flat Earth they believe it yeah yeah
people believe it I get [ __ ] [ __ ]
every day from people that are flattered
with supporters that are mad at me for
disposing they just want to believe it
that's real it is a weird thing with and
by the way one of the main guys who send
to Flat Earth makes it has a whole video
about how jujitsu doesn't work and it's
about Wing Chun isn't there like one of
his biggest videos on his page yeah yeah
hilarious but there is something about
people wanting to believe that there's
mysteries and secrets that there's like
some secret power yeah like in that you
know the idea that you could just center
yourself and a college wrestler can't
take you down yeah that's one of my new
things that I tell people with your
jutsu because I used to say like jujitsu
is magic cuz cuz it kind of is you know
when you know jujitsu you can do things
that are almost
magic right but then when you're
teaching somebody for the first time
almost like look it's it's not magic
it's you know I've always shown when
somebody the other day of you know elbow
escape or something from the mount and
the guys like yeah you know he's it's
really hard to do because he keeps
pulling my arm away you know yeah it's a
fight urine yeah it's not magic it's you
have to fight against the other person
to another human I just told him what to
do and I told you what to do now you
gotta fight for it yeah you got to
figure out how to get to the right
position yeah he's not magic but it is
weird that people that you know they're
they're looking for something to believe
in I guess yeah and maybe they just want
a contrary and viewpoints so that's why
they pick saying that the earth is flat
well I also think it's it's sort of the
same thing with people wanting shortcuts
going down this road the end of podcast
I'm out people a lot of shortcuts they
love like like they love like throwing
out the the entire paradigm of modern
civilization it's all based on a lie
we're not on a globe we're on a flat
disc do you ever spins around us like
this maybe you know people that just
like to argue is this maybe just people
that like to argue and have a country
I'm gonna be some of them for sure that
could be some of them for some of them I
think it's just that they're people that
straight up just straight up believe
that the earth is 100% 100% in your soul
yeah yeah yeah they really believe it
but there's also people to join the
Moonies you know this being a joint
solid Scientology yeah I mean look
there's people out there that'll suck a
dick if they think it'll make them live
forever they sure soak your dick I might
live forever yes the knowledge will flow
through you but you have to believe like
yeah one down in San Diego I don't know
what it was ten years ago 15 years ago
they had that Heaven's Gate thing where
all those bands put on those purple
shoes he put on the purple Nikes yeah
they killed themselves in the comet was
flying by yeah and it shows you again
you know now we're you're talking about
the human mind is just so complicated
and complex that it's grasping for
something to believe in and some people
aren't gonna believe in anything yeah
[Applause]
[Music]